feeding
and milking the cows cleaning out the
stables
a daily routine for farmer byram alician
turk
but the stall next door holds his true
passion
his dromedaries they are treated to a
daily wellness program
byram massages their joints and necks
not to improve their carrying of burdens
but to prepare them
for wrestling matches
they love these massages it relaxes them
and gives them energy
the drum dribbles don't look aggressive
on first sight
but bioram knows why they wear their
muzzles
it's in their nature to assert
themselves against rivals
that's why we don't have to train them
for the matches we just give them love
a town on turkey's aegean sea coast
there's no desert here
and camels aren't indigenous but the
inhabitants forebears came from central
asia
and brought the tradition of camel
wrestling with them
a big match is scheduled this weekend in
this dusty sports arena
the first spectators have already
arrived and the atmosphere is festive
the contestants have come from far and
wide
first the animals wait in a parking
garage
then the richly adorned candidates strut
their stuff in a procession through the
town of thirty thousand
most of the owners are poor farmers who
hope to earn a little extra cash with
the prize money
for boston the camel wrestling match is
the high point of the year
camel wrestling is a centuries-old
tradition we cultivate it
and by doing that we honor our nomadic
ancestors
byram has come for a look at the
competition before the matches begin
the owners all know each other almost
all winter long the camel's rushing
season they went their way along the
aegean coast to the various arenas
some animals like to attack from the
left others from the right
i know the wrestling style of most of
the animals here
on byram's farm the animals are prepared
for the fight
they're fitted with heavy saddles the
competition is not only about a few
hundred euros in prize money
but also the glory of victory everyone's
in suspense
the dromedaries too
they know something's different today
are we going to make it to the finals
will everything come off without any
accidents
these thoughts stress both the camel and
me
then the caravan sets off it's five
kilometers to the arena
on match days the camel drivers all wear
traditional
orange and white plaid neckerchiefs
people have been streaming into the
venues since early morning
some spectators follow the route of the
camel wrestling matches from one coastal
town to the next
a lot of rocky turkish snaps is being
downed at the picnic tables
rocky and camel wrestling are both part
of the fun you need both
a stand sells camel sausage so even
camels that can't wrestle anymore
contribute to the celebration
the athletes march one last time past
the grandstand
where the local notables have their
places
the first two contestants are released a
match lasts five minutes
the winner is the camel that knocks over
his opponent pushes him aside
or gets him in a headlock there are
different weight classes and a referee
to keep his animal from being injured an
owner can give up by throwing the lead
rope into the middle
this is tunahan he foamed at his mouth
and looks quite aggressive
the owners say that the camels love to
wrestle but the criticism of animal
rights activists to this tradition
is getting louder
the people in boston pay no attention to
such criticism
byram's strongest bull camel is up next
his name is ozgoorhan and byram wants
him to make the finals
the spectators are having a grand time
ausgurhan throws himself on his
opponent's neck
but the other bull manages to stay on
his feet
byram doesn't leave his camel's side the
match ends in a draw
i'm happy nevertheless it was a fair
fight
he fought well and we were actually
ahead on points
despite the tie ozgurhan and his proud
owner receive a trophy
now they can rest from their exertions
it'll be another year before the arena
is open to the dromedaries again